about a couple weeks ago i think now um
i propose the skeptics
principle the principle of the skeptic
what is that it's a principle that says
that
you should become an enemy of everything
you read
comes from our good friend uh al hazen
uh he was a 10th to 11th century
arab and considered one of the first
scientists or at least pragmatic guys he
studied
optics and so on and he said you know
you got to become an
enemy of everything you read and you can
extrapolate that just
one inch further and say you have to be
a skeptic of
everything you believe and that you know
okay with quotations you have to become
a skeptic of everything you know
and that means you have to attack it
from the start you have to attack
your own theories your own beliefs as
much as you possibly
can try to put yourself on the other
side of the fence
it's not easy to do easy to say but not
it's hard to do you know
and the only thing you can do is you
know try to keep an open mind and see if
you can attack your theory so that you
become
solid in them well you know if you don't
do it someone else will
and that is option number two you know
if you've
already looked at your theory your
proposals and you say well you know i
attacked it from every angle that i can
think of
i'm going to put it out there and i'm
going to take it to someone who who
doesn't like it who
instinctively says there's something's
wrong with your theory
okay so what's wrong and so the other
person will
look for holes in your theory and what
that does
it forces you to raise your shield and
your sword and defend it you know now
you gotta
try to defend your theory and that's
good because uh
now you know what other people are
what's going through the minds of other
people
it's like you're getting a brainstorm
you know and you say oh i didn't think
about that
let's see let me let me look at this and
maybe you don't have an immediate answer
maybe you do you know maybe you already
thought about it
but you can see where other people are
coming from how they're attacking your
theory
and that's good it's a it's good to put
your theory to
that kind of exposure